[Müzik]
gördüğünüz kızla tanıştırayım sizi
4 yaşındayım 4 yaşındaki Kübra ve o
dönem
o zamanlar Aslında küçükken
dünyanın çok italyangaç
kendi düşüncelerini söyleyemeyen ifade
edemeyen bir insan bu aslında
yaptırmak istediğimde ya da söylemek
istediğimde anneme ya da Aileme söyler
dim iyi senelerdim Ama tabi bu küçük
Ken okuldayken
ortaokuldayken Türkiye ama sizin gibi
liseye geldiğimde Aslında bu işin öyle
olmadığını da öğrendim yani bir takım
zorlukları kendi kabuğundan çıkarak
açmaya çalışmam gerekiyordu
Aslında
yavaş yavaş sessizliğin gücüyle yapmaya
çalıştım
şöyle
Bazı insanlar etkileşimleri iletişimleri
çok daha oluyken çok daha direkt
iletişime geçerken Bazısı ise daha
sessiz
[Müzik]
ithamların yapısı ve ben sessizliğin
gücünü orada kullanmaya başladım
lisedeyken kullan
Maya bak davranışlarını öğrenmeye Acaba
neden böyle konuşuyorlar Neden böyle
hareket ediyorlar ya da onların o
sonuçlarını Başarılarını Hatta bazı
insanın başarılı olup olmadığını ve bu
başarısının sonucunda da o sessizliğin
gücüyle
bir takım sonuçlara varabiliyorum ve
bunu da kendi hayatımı Aslında
yansıtmaya başlamıştım
Lise sona doğru
bir işte hayata bakış açım da keza
bakıyorum konuşuyorum seninle normal
şeylerden bahsed
iyorsun ve birazcık fazla da çalışsan
kendi derslerinde çalışsam ve Hedef
sonrasında benim hayatımda neler değişir
Bunu bir gözlemleyelim mi seninle dedi
birazcık ders çalışmaya başla daha fazla
Daha doğrusu ders çalışmaya
başladı ve tabi hedefimle diyerek hayat
kurmaya başladım ondan önce çok daha
Hayat kurmazdım sessizlikle Evet bunları
bir anlamda insanların hayallerini
Empati kurarak çözmeye çalışırdım Ama
baktığımızda bir hedefim yoktu benim
takip ise sona kadar
Aslında üniversiteleri araştırmaya
başladım hangi üniversitede okurum diye
düşündüm hayal ettim
Aslında hangisi benim için daha iyi olur
Hangi bölümde okumak istiyorum
bana ne katar diye düşünmeye başlarken
bir yandan da inanın gece gündüz
çalıştım
ve
bizim ÖSS deniliyordu şu anda farklı
sistem oldu ses ses sınavında çalıştım
puanla da
sıralamalarımızı yapacağız Bütün
arkadaşlarım işte Farklı farklı
üniversiteler yazıyor O döneme göre çoğu
üniversiteye ve bölüme girebiliyordum
zaten arkadaşlar ve bir bölümü vardı
o bölüm
roblox teknik üniversitesinden bakıyoruz
hem de okuyacağımız bir bölümdü
kendi Kab
uğunda diyorum ya Evet artık sessizliğin
gücünü de öğrendim ve o kabuktan nasıl
çıkabileceğimi de anladım yurt dışında
bir şeyler yaparak en başta da okuyarak
Aslında Sonra şöyle bir yanımı anlatayım
ben size arkadaşlar ailemle beraber
listeliyoruz bütün
üniversitelerini listeliyoruz en başında
da bu üniversiteye yazdım ve bu bölümü
yazdım yurtdışında da okuyacağım ailem
Hani başta Tamam dedi Çok güzel bölüm
dedi aslında Hem yurt dışında hem
yurtdışında okuyabileceği ile
kendileri de online
bıraktım
başvuruyu yapacağım
evrakları vereceğim ve artık biliyorum
yani kazanacağım zaten bu bölümü Çünkü
benim puanım çok daha yüksekti Aslında
budur falan
ailem dedi ki; yani Kübra acaba dedi Bu
bölüme gitmesem mi Aslında ikilelik de
Aslında bizleri bütün Türk ailelerimizin
bahsettiği hep şöyle bir konu kızım
okusun çok güzel yerlerde ya da oğlum
Ama yanımızda da olabilir diye böyle bir
düşündürdüler beni açık
çası o anda kendi inandığımız yol mor
mor Aslında önemli
başkalarının söylediği Tabii ki
Allah'tan burada Ailelerimiz çoğunlukla
değil de olsaydı zaten şu anda beni de
dinlemeden önce psikolojik şeylerdi ama
inanın ben o günümü yazdım o bölümden
mezun oldum
hiç de pişman olmadım ve ailemin de
pişman olduğunu düşünmüyorum ama bak
tım farklı farklı düşünceler
sürüyor diyebilirim
şimdi herkes bahsediyordur sizi açıkçası
İşte üniversiteye kapak at Gerisi gelir
Üniversiteye giriş ya da o bölümü Kazan
devamında her şey olur
her şey çok daha iyi olacakmış gibi
bahsediliyor
bir şey yok yani keşke
olsa hepimiz için çok daha basit olurdu
ama bizim için gerçekten de çok önemli
bir konu İyi bir üniversiteye giriş
yap şöyle düşünün bizim Aslında
beynimizin içi tamamiyle yeşilliklerle
dolu ve biz oraya bir fidan dikiyoruz O
Fidan yavaş yavaş büyüyor Koskocaman bir
ağaç oluyor işte o bir üniversite
[Müzik]
Gerisi gelir tabi üniversiteye ben çok
çalıştım gerçekten de o dönem çok yoğun
olduğu
için giriş yaptıktan sonra arkadaşlar
gerisi gelir
3 yılda bitir
iyorsa yapacaksınız
mikro
fon İlk sınıfta gireceğiz
benim için ilk sınavda ve arkadaşların
da şöyle bahsediyordu belki hiç
çalışmıyoruz işte sınavımız olacak ama
işte öyle Kitap bile açmadık ben
[Müzik]
sınavdan
evinden 9 aldım
ve 9
arkadaşlarım 60-70 işte 80'lerde
Kübra dedi
[Müzik]
ilk sınav olduğu için zaten
öyle bir şey yapmışız bana dedi dediler
ki dedim
Hadi devam
[Müzik]
daha kabuğundan çıkmaya devam ettim
Dolayısıyla Bu arada o sınavdan
sonrasında telafi yaparak çok daha iyi
puanlar aldım Hala hocamızla görüşüyorum
kendisi bütün derslerine
konu olarak beni çağırıyor ve bu
hikayeyi de çoğu yerde anlatıyorum
açıkçası
sonrasında
gerçekten de her
bazı şeyleri Hem de kendi kabuğumuzdan
çıktıkça
çok daha bütünsel görebiliyoruz çok daha
güzel
anekdotlar ortaya çıkıyor
Seda mezun
oldum bakıyorum ekipteki Tek yabancı
benim Türküm diğerleri
Amerika başlarım her şey çok güzel falan
işte kültürleri öğrenmeye çalışıyorum
yani insanları gözlemliyorum bu arada
oskif hala Birazcık var
[Müzik]
şimdi bu arada hep
raporlu cüzdanda çıktı alıyorum
ve
işi var iki tane arkadaşım
ın var
aldığım bununla uğraşıyorum film yapayım
diye
Hiç öyle yapamadım
5 dakika bir saat sürdü ve hiç kimse
orada bana dönüp de ne yapıyorsun inanın
demedi
saatin sonunda
elektrikten ya da makineden hiç
anlamayan ben onu çözdüm
ve yaptım Sonrasında da kendime aşırı
bir Güven geldi ve dedim ki evet Kübra
bu kabuktan iyice çıkmaya başladı
bütün farklılığı o kadar değişik ki
onca hem aklımda şu düşünce vardı ya
işte bizde olsa
ve onlar yanınızda gelir ne yapıyorsun
der Hatta
kız Yani bir saat boyunca orada
ne yapılır bir anlamda da benimle kendi
kabuğumdan çıkarmaya çok daha kolay
gitti ve birazcık daha güven
miş şimdi baktığımızda sonrasında okulum
bitti iş hayatında atıldım iş
dünyasındaki Kübra Yıldız'a göster
mek size tabii ki de burada da yine
birçok zorlukla karşılaşıyor muyuz Evet
karşılaşıyoruz
işte kadın olmanın zorluğu genç olmanın
zorluğu şu anda zaten sizlerin bile
kendi işleri kendi projeleri fikirleri
olan birçok kişi vardı burada diye
düşünüyorum Hatta o projeleri
yürütüyor muzu kırdıkça bunların
başarı katıyoruz daha fazla başarı
adımlarını basamaklarla ilerletiyoruz
daha Aslında bunların hepsini şu anda
[Müzik]
hiçbir de belki de anlatabiliyorum ama o
gün bana sorsaydınız bunların hepsi
gerçekten de benim için çok büyük
zorluklardı
Freud'un bir
cümlesinde bir gün geriye dönüp
baktığımızda mücadele yıllarımız Aslında
bizim en güzel zamanlarımız olarak
hatırlanacaktır ve zorluklar
mücadele etmek bizim başarımıza başarı
katacak
gerçekten de yağmurda yürüme ile
Bilmemiz gerekiyor
[Alkış]